She's gone.
She's coming back. I am almost positive.
Almost!?
Why do I listen to you? Why? You were wrong
about the iPod being a failure. You were
wrong about tomato being a vegetable. I don't
even want to talk about your favorite planet,
Pluto.
And unless she was lying to the good
ladies of The View, it's Demi.
Not Demi!
You were going to let me go with him!?
Isn't that what you wanted, honey?
What's the matter with you? You've been acting so weird
ever since I left college.
For the record, you didn't leave college. You
were asked to leave.
Oh, which you guys never let me forget.
Especially Dad.
Honey, your father-
Oh, you don't have to tell me what he thinks, okay?
I'm a huge disappointment to him. I see it on his
face every day.
He acts as if he doesn't even want me around.
Give me the ticket for the car.
Phil-
I'm going after her.
This little chicken game may work for your dad,
but it doesn't work for me.
That's my little girl.
I need her to know that no guy on earth is good
enough for her,
Let alone some slimy, middle-aged jean salesman.
What's this?
Just enjoy it.